this is what we are trying to explain to
people that these services people
believe we're for free I open up for
free and taxpayers pay those services
hello my name is Juna runga with reason
TV and i'm here with richard de Rana of
the institute of economic and social
studies and slovakia thank you very much
for joining us tell us a bit about your
Institute I am the institute of economic
and social studies that is based in
Bratislava Slovakia this is our fifth
year and what we do is we are publishing
the analysis and policy papers we are
organizing conferences and we around a
couple of educational project our basic
mission is to explain the principles of
free markets why is this important to
tell to people who come from a
previously communist regime so lucky did
quite a few successful economic reforms
couple of years ago and as a result we
were one of the fastest growing
economies in the European Union for a
couple of years for instance two years
ago we grew over ten percent so there
were like flat tax reform introduced we
did a reform of the healthcare or
thought of the pensions pms and
obviously we are a post communist
country so there is a no tradition of
thinking about the size of the
government and this is what we are
trying to explain to people that these
services people believe we're for free
are not for free and taxpayers pay those
services and tell us about this program
that you're currently receiving the
Templeton Liberty award for the project
is called the price of the state and it
started as a single website internet
website you can see their government
revenues you can see their government
expenditures it is a complete
information on public finance in my
country and there are a few interactive
features like for instance each shop
called by your own state
where you can play by your own state
state yes state so that you can click on
whatever service provided by style you
prefer and when you submit your shopping
the size of your state appears and also
the information how much the taxis could
be decreased if the side if the state
was was according to your preferences if
I hear you right you have a website that
has comprehensive data on the cost of
every government service and one can
even break it down into what it costs
each citizen exactly and under by your
own state people can compare what the
cost of buying certain services from the
government is versus buying it from the
from the private sector or how do they
express their preference this is
actually the aim of our project to to
tell people that the services are really
expensive because we are not trying to
to use these sort of dogmatic positions
we are not telling people government is
beak and we have to limit it because
once you tell people the explicit
dogmatic position they just create Iraq
the barrier between you and them so and
envio your program you said you've
managed to get it into the education
system tell us a bit about that yeah
there was another step we prepared the
teaching tools for teachers and the air
since we are sending these sort of set
of materials to all high schools and to
all universities around the country and
the response in general is very good i
mean people teachers are asking us to
come today or schools and to deliver
lectures in other words to show them how
to how to present all those information
on public finance so are you seeing your
kind of activity of being adopted by
other countries yes and we are very
happy that this project is spreading
like a virus right now there is also the
price of
state for czech republic and also for
for the poland so the people from these
three countries including slovakia and
can now compare how the individual
governments are using and spending the
money of the taxpayers and what are
their preferences so this is the way how
we can create a sort of pressure on the
effective use of the money of the
taxpayers well thank you very much for
joining us Richard for reason TV this is
junior run go